hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from match four of
the finals of the magnus crossing chess
tour
it's again carlson with the white pieces
against nakamura now we've seen the
first game where magnus also almost got
a win with the white pieces then game
two ended in a draw and now we are in
game three
so this one's even crazier so uh let's
check it out
magnus with the white pieces opens with
e for this time
sorry about that uh so will we see
another berlin we have e5
well what happens uh we have e5 knight
of three
and now knight to c6 uh by uh by hikaru
uh just to give me a second there
sorry the interface is being weird
huh right there we go
uh knight to c6 and bishop to c4 here
uh magnus doesn't go for bishop to b5 so
we don't have the real opus it's the
italian game we have bishop to c5 by
hikaru
and here i guess magnus was just all mad
and fuming about not winning game one so
here he decides to go for the evans
gambit
that uh that of course is a joke he
doesn't he goes for the joko piano
and the knight to f6 by nakamura and now
we have uh the the main line we have d6
d3 d6 c3 and h6 bikey car
rook to e1 and now mag hikaru just
castles uh like we said always bishop
knight g4 isn't really anything because
you can play rookie too
the rook will be fine here and you can
push the knight back on the next move
just in case you play this
so castles and the knight b to d2
preparing the usual stuff not coming
here to g3
we have a5 and now knight to f1
re-maneuvering the knight with bishop to
e6 and now bishop to b5 so this is all
well known
knights the e7 and now that the knight
is being shifted away to either g6 or
helping out with the push of d5
the knight no longer controls d4 so d4
by magnus
e capresen d for c captures and bishop
to b6 with knight to g3
so the remaneuvering of the knight is
complete and now b5 by hikar we have e5
and 94 and this is where the
uh game basically starts the knight
captures uh this is an old move but
knight captures on e4 is the only move
that was ever played in this position
here magnus goes back with bishop to d3
and it is now as of move 15 that we have
a completely new game so let's see how
he car deals with this he trades on g3
uh we have captures and captures and the
now pushes
uh pushes a4 uh so taking away the
the b3 square from the from the white
queen also preparing a3
uh to create some weaknesses on the
queen side and semi open the
file for his rook on a8 bishop the c2 by
magnus trying to exploit
this uh uh this diagonal with a3 by
hikaru
and here magnus just captures uh b
captures on a3 he doesn't mind
messing up his pawn structure uh we have
bishop to g4 now
and a4 now uh freeing up the a3 square
for his bishop
we have queen to b7 uh and now bishop to
a3
and here of course the knight is pinned
so hikaru would definitely like to move
it the rook to e8 on pins here
and now magnus says okay even though i
do have the bishop pair
i will give up my dark square bishop
because this knight is a very strong
defender
so queen captures and already queen here
uh threatening queen to h7 check
king here and queen to h8 mate so g6 is
a must
uh g6 by hikaru and now knight to h4 and
here
uh a very interesting moment that i
think happens to a lot of great
attackers here he car plays queen to b4
and he doesn't think that anything
anything bad can happen to him because
he's attacking the d4 pawn and it's not
easy for magnus to defend this
uh however magnus doesn't need to defend
his because here magnus just goes
knight captures on g6 and we've reached
the position from the thumbnail
so knight captures on g6 uh the reason
i'm not asking you to pause the video
and find night captures on g6 because i
will ask you to pause the video two more
times in this game
so i thought maybe three times would be
too much because there are better things
to find in this game believe me
so here uh hikaru of course if if he
captures then it's just captures and his
game over if here queen queen h7 is made
and if king of faith then you can just
start gobbling up everything
check queen king e7 checking here queen
captures with
check and you've regained your material
while grabbing a lot of pawns here and
this is just of course completely
winning for
uh for magnus so here after knight
captures and g6
we have queen capture sunday for by
hikaru and now you could trade queens
but magnus finds something even better
97 check he keeps the queens on the
board now this is coming
and uh capturing doesn't work because
check king moves and queen the h8 is
checkmate so you can do this so after 97
check
king to f8 by hikaru and now magnus just
goes
knight captures on d5 says okay i've
grabbed the pawn
and now uh we're we're we can create
queens and we can just uh
nicely play this end game so here uh
what do you play
well there are a couple of things you
can play because this is basically
uh the the most important position of
the game
so here hikaru is free to trade queens
of course captures captures and now
let's say bishop a5
doesn't allow this capture you harass
the rook here rook moves and let's say
rook
88 and you continue playing this
position being down two pawns however
white has a double a pawn so probably
you would be able to take advantage of
this
so instead after knight captures on b5
hikaru doesn't trade queens
uh the other good move is the rook
captures an e5
just grabbing that pawn also if rook
captures you have captures
but then you then we probably see knight
characters on v6
a trait of queens captures characters
characters with check
rook characters and just c characters
and v6 we would get this position where
uh white is still up upon
uh but it is uh very much playable so
here after look to e3
uh sorry after this knight captures on
b5 hikaru doesn't go for this
like we've shown doesn't go for this
like we've shown he goes for the thing
you've all been wondering why not
bishop why not queen characters on f2
and this is exactly what he does so
queen captures on f2
uh we have king to h2 by magnus and now
rook a to d8 and it seems like
everything is
fine the knight is under attack c6 is
coming you're gonna harass the knight
uh a lot of very interesting
possibilities here even the bishop is
guarding the g1 square so maybe if the
queen can
find her way to let's say h5 maybe you
can just win instantly
but there's a problem so feel free to
pause the video here and
win the game for magnus while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
only move that
wins the game here for magnus and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
rook to f1 and now the reason why rook
to f1 is so strong because the
the move that uh well everyone uh was
looking at
rook captures on d5 deflecting the queen
from the defense of the bishop here
doesn't work because after queen
captures you just get mated with queen
captures on f7
so the only good move and by good i mean
still losing however the most resilient
one
is bishop to f5 you just attack white's
queen
and this is the most fun we've had in a
long time here
queen the a3 check now if the king moves
you just pick up the queen
so the queen has to block but now comes
the beauty queen to c1
and now the the thing is yes you are you
are attacking this twice
however if you capture this queen
captures an h6 check the e7 uh square is
guarded by the knight
so king j8 and knight f6 is checkmate so
this uh this will not work uh on the
other hand after queen to c1
you could decide to capture the knight
on d5 but then again is just queen
captures an h6
check and it doesn't matter where the
king goes because if you go here then
queen to h4 check and now
of course if you go here then rook 81
just just wins
but there really are no are no better
squares if you go king to f8 then you
get
real captures on f5 this is covered and
you're just
you're just getting checkmated here not
not much for you to do here
uh whatever you do it's like just this
and this this checkmate the queen covers
e7
uh it would be pointless so after queen
to c1 you could try rook the e6 to just
prevent queen to h6 which is also a
possibility
but then bishop captures an f5 you offer
a queen trade
of course black will will decline this
he's going to pick up a piece but now
bishop captures queen captures and rook
f6 again
you gain access to the to the h6 pawn
captures captures with check
king to e7 and now rook a2 f1 and here
black is down the exchange white is on
the attack it's completely winning for
white uh easy game
so when i say bishop f5 is the best move
for black i mean
also losing but definitely the most
resilient one hikaru gives up the queen
by playing rook captures on e5
so we have rook captures on f2 and now
rook d captures on d5 but now
for the last and final time uh pause the
video and find
the quickest and only way to win for
white while i give you a couple of
seconds because as you can see
the rook is being threatened uh if you
move the rook the g1 square is covered
rook to h5 is coming
so it's basically hikaru who is
threatening checkmate here so
have at it
so uh for those of you who were once
again able to do it congratulations on
spotting the once again only winning
move and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's rook captures an
f7 with
check once you know that if you move the
rook and this delivers mate
uh you know that you have to move with
tempo so
rook captures on f7 and he covered the
clients the rook because if you capture
the rook then you have
rook to f1 check king to e7 and now
queen to h7 with check let's say king d6
and now comes queen g6 check attacking
the bishop
but after the bishop blocks you still
have to guard against this
rook to h5 now bishop b1 and white is
out of the woods
there is no checkmate anymore the game
can continue but the black
white is of material it's a very easy
game so here after will captures on f7
he carl played king the e8
uh and we have uh queen captures on v5
now by magnus also the cleanest way to
do this
uh rook captures and now bishop to g6
threatening a lot of nasty discoveries
so king d8 and now rook to e1 magnus
showing off his
material advantage uh we have c6 and now
rook captures on b7 we have bishop to c7
uh
giving the king uh an escape route to
the seventh friend
but now rookie eight try king d7 and the
rook the eighth hit by magnus
and it was in this position on move 36
that hikaru nakamura resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
rook to h7 is coming you cannot go king
here because the recovers the
back ring and after this the bishop just
falls
yeah if you try something like this
still check you can block uh again
you lose the bishop and the white is now
up a whole rook
so after rook h8 hikaru resigned and
after game three
magnus takes the lead in the fourth
match so will we see uh
and uh and uh e equalization after the
the fourth match or will he carl be able
to bounce back and force the the blitz
playoffs
so we'll see what happens uh that's the
game i do hope you enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank russell lloyd
now magdy montgomery uh scott melissa
richard furman and cassie johnson for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the finals checking up on
your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day